what was the very first topic that we
started this year do you remember yep
integers integers perfect now you
remember I made a big deal about the
name integers and it had a meaning right
what was it what why integers called
into duty above it exactly right an
integer right when we get to an integral
from which means you know all in one
piece not falling apart
it means whole okay and now we are
looking at fractions now I think you
guys can do a pretty good job here I'm
gonna ask you to do this on your own for
a second I want you to write down a
definition for fractions are okay and I
expect you'll get a few different ones
okay but I want you to write down
because I know you've met these before I
want to see what kinds of meanings
definitions give me a sentence what is a
fraction okay I'll give you I'll give
you some time to write that down and
then I'll share we'll hear some of what
you have to say okay all right so let's
see what we can come up with let me get
my other color
all right yes shaking whoa section 4
part of what site hey all the shape okay
excellent I love this idea okay let's go
in the front yep if action is a part of
a
okay out of a hole and then you might
have something off of this number shape
something like that okay good
can someone give me one that's different
your job pot of hot of so it being part
of things that right a part of anything
okay can someone give me anything
different yes no ton of this not oh okay
alright one more huh oh they're a little
part of everything a little part may I
put it on that's something you do that
okay all right now does they don't have
anything that's dramatically different
to any of these all right now
I like all of these ideas I think we're
getting at it right now I don't you can
see why I worked at integers first
because fractions are very much a
contrast to introduce right there is the
sin be called but integers sounds like a
word you know that means all right
fractions sounds like another word you
knew it doesn't it right does it not
sound like match our fracture when you
yes generally integers are whole numbers
because integral means hold right in one
piece but fractions they're broken
numbers they're numbers that have been
split apart divided okay are literally
fractured into pieces and you only have
a part of it and you saw that language
there this is one of many kinds of
numbers integers or some fraction but
there are many other clients but
fraction is what we're going to focus on
fly this topic okay